so our search for David in his own City
reveals only a tunnel that might tell us
of his clever tactics but precious
little else about David himself
but it turns out that the best evidence
we have for davidon comes not from his
city or his people but from his arch
enemies
David the Bible says was a superb
military ruler
after establishing his kingdom with its
capital in Jerusalem David led the
Israelites from one victory to another
in battles against his might neighbors
the Moabites the Edomites the ammonites
and the Arameans
with this conquered land if he
established the davidic empire that
extended over both sides of the Jordan
River as far as the Mediterranean Sea
paving the way for his son Solomon to
inherit a strong Empire in which for the
first time it was safe to build the holy
temple and finally housed the holiest of
holy relics the Ark of the Covenant
and the greatest testament to David's
importance and as yet the most tangible
clue that David was a real human made of
flesh and blood comes from an enemy king
who records a victory over David's
descendants on a piece of stone called
the tailed on Stella Matilda and Stella
is a monumental stone inscription
incised with letters it is written in
Aramaic put up by an Aramaic King who
claims that he has conquered 70 cities
and he is setting up this particular
Stella to commemorate this occasion one
of the conquests he claims shook
Biblical Archaeology to its core the six
letters say that the vide there's the
bit and the you'd the top the Dalit
above and then again the Dalit Beth
Aveda between every other words in this
inscription there is a very clear dot
but between these two words bate and
daveed there is no dot which has been
interpreted as meaning that this was a
concept even though it was made up of
two words
these words be at dahveed when
translated into english read house of
david this is the first time the house
of david or even the name david has been
found in a non biblical source